in the lobby of financial peace Plaza
Tracy is with us hi Tracy welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Thank You great to be
here good to have you and who's this
hanging on this is Emma she's my
six-year-old I am me how are you it's
good to have you well welcome where do
you guys live Greensboro North Carolina
fun well welcome to Nashville
so I'm guessing you're here in the
financial piece Plaza Lobby to do your
debt free scream yes we are
I love it so how much have you paid off
forty one thousand five hundred eighty
seven dollars and three cents I love it
how long did that take 14 months Wow
you've been killing it what's your
income started out making eighty nine
nine and ended up making sixty-three
base okay very take a pay cut
took a pay cut why I was actually laid
off right in the middle of everything
mm-hmm basically um found out last
January that they were gonna be making
some major sales cuts at my company and
so decided it was time to buckle down
with the budget and really start looking
at things and figure out how to get
everything paid off so what do you do
I'm in pharmaceutical sales okay of
course great good for you
very cool very cool so what kind of debt
was the 40 mm it was a credit card was a
good chunk of it paid off the car got a
mattress
yeah nice huh quality mattress that I'm
trying to pay off I loved it there was
some unemployment debt basically they
overpaid me when I was unemployed and
then that wonderful overdraft that so
many of us tend to rely on yeah
understand yeah very cool so you're a
single mom I am a single mom okay Nate
fun fun fun
well good for you so what do you tell
single moms out there that have $42,000
in debt you just did this I think it's
just a matter of looking at the short
term versus the long term the the short
term you know it just seems so much
easier to just say yes and just give in
to the easy way to do things we also eat
healthy so people just kind of thought
oh well you're just gonna have to give
up on that you don't have the ability to
do that and it's just staying focused on
what the goal of it is and wait what it
is you're gonna be teaching your
children because at the end of the day
what I'm trying to teach Emmy is to do
the right things and be responsible with
her money instead of just to you know do
what feels good good very cool very cool
well you did it I'm proud of you I feel
great it does it feels amazing
love it very fun all right well let's
count it down get Emmy ready we got to
do a good debt free scream here and me
Amy's working this all right
$42,000 paid off in 14 months making 89
now 63 thousand dollars and it's Tracy
and Emmy from Greensboro North Carolina
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one that was worth it
right there I love it
congratulations Wow how neat very very
fun
you